Hi. My name is Kat. I'm a senior design
and developer advocate at Progress
Software, and I have spent most of my
career focused on the front end.
After taking a somewhat meandering path
through design and into development, I
eventually found my niche in the space
where those two worlds overlap.
My design background has given me a lot
of insight into the UX side of software
engineering, and the user research that
I get to do as part of my work as
developer advocate is one of my favorite
parts of the world.
I have spent a lot of my career teaching
developers about design, about UX, and
about how to build more user-friendly
software.
Something that's always been valuable,
but is more crucial than ever now that
AI has entered the picture.
I don't need to tell you that AI is a
pretty unique new technology.
It is rapidly developing and has so much
potential to improve systems and
software in ways that we couldn't have
even dreamed of just a few years ago.
However, along with all of that
potential is also quite a bit of risk.
AI's non-deterministic nature means that
the output can wildly range in quality,
format, style, and accuracy, even when
we're trying our best to prevent that.
On top of that, it requires entirely new
types of interaction patterns to use.
In fact, we've seen the emergence of new
vocabulary, techniques, and sometimes
entire roles meant to address that need.
For those of us that are living and
breathing this technology every day,
concepts like prompt engineers,
hallucinations, retrieval augmented
generation, and so much more have all
become regular parts of our lives.
But for the vast majority of our users,
that simply isn't the case yet.
In any kind of technology, there's a gap
between the developer, who has by nature
kind of become the subject matter
expert, and the user.
The technical literacy of the average
software engineer is always going to be
higher than the average user of said
software.
That's where UX comes in. It's how we
bridge the gap between what we intended
when we built an application and what
the user actually experiences.
After all, it doesn't actually matter
what our software can do if our users
hate using it so much that they will
avoid it at all costs.
And right now, AI has a kind of serious
UX problem.
Our users are seeing AI features get
added to basically everything right now,
from their work software to their social
media apps, right down to their computer
and phone operating systems.
But, as a wise technologist once said,
"Your scientists were so preoccupied
with whether or not they could, they
didn't stop to think if they should."
We're really pushing our users to adopt
these new tools and features, but we're
not always making it easy to do so.
It's common to see situations where a
user is presented with a poorly designed
AI feature that they really only have
the barest idea how to use.
Then, when they try it and it doesn't do
what they wanted or expected it to do,
they feel annoyed and off-put and kind
of negative about AI generally.
The more times they try an AI feature
and get sub-par results, the less likely
they are to engage with it again in the
future.
Which means that, as the creators of
these features and software,
we really only have so many chances to
get this right before our users just
disengage and stop trying at all.
In my personal opinion, this knowledge
gap between developer and user when it
comes to AI is one of the widest that
I've seen with any technology.
That makes it extremely hard for us to
build AI-powered features that our users
are actually going to get the full
benefit from.
When Macintosh introduced their
graphical user interface, it was, like
AI is now, something that was very
different and unfamiliar to their users.
But a large part of their success and
reputation was built on their ability to
create a user experience that met users
where they were.
They borrowed vocabulary and user flows
from real life. They included lots of
icons and visual representations, and
they really made sure to walk users
through how to get the most out of their
new personal computers.
And over time, as the average user
became more comfortable and more
literate in the space, the user
experience of the Macintosh evolved with
them. We start to see more technical
terms and fewer abstractions.
Look at the difference here between the
control panels in Macintosh system 1 and
system 6.
If you had presented a system 1 user
with the words rate of insertion point
blinking or RAM cache, it would have
been pretty much meaningless to them.
Similarly, we see that those low and
high volume icons are gone in system 6,
along with the little turtle and rabbit
speed icons, right? That kind of more
literal depiction wasn't needed anymore.
Right now, we are probably somewhere
around system 3 in this metaphor of
introducing AI to users.
We may not need the turtle and rabbit
icons anymore, but we also can't yet
assume that they will sit down with our
AI software as experts.
The good news here is that, unlike the
Macintosh UI, we're not totally starting
from scratch here.
Our users have existing mental models
about software usage that's going to
carry over to what we're building.
They're just not always going to map
over exactly one to one.
But that's where we come in.
As developers, it's our role to leverage
these patterns that our users are
already familiar with, start to combine
them in new ways, and then introduce
them to our users gradually in a way
that's not going to feel overwhelming.
A good user experience will not only
provide a user with the tools, but also
guide them how to use them.
For instance, let's look at an AI chat
interface.
From a purely UI perspective, chatting
with an LLM is almost, but not quite,
like chatting with another user.
So, we'll be able to borrow some
familiar patterns here, like having the
user's chats show up on one side and the
AI chats on the other, messages that
appear above an input field with a send
button, a scrollable message history,
and more.
That gives our users a really good
jumping off point and a lot of visual
clues about how to start interacting
with an AI chat.
However, the experience isn't quite
close enough that we can just lift an
existing interface from direct messages
and repurpose it wholesale.
A chat interface that was originally
built for two people is not going to
have the accommodations that we need for
things like adding reference sources,
pausing or stopping an in-progress reply
from the LLM, leveraging agentic tools
and integrations, or more.
So, those are going to be the places
where we have to adapt existing UX and
UI patterns into something new.
We have to be the bridge and help our
users transition into familiarity with
these new AI experiences.
We can see the difference here, right?
Compared this Copilot research agent new
chat with the new Teams chat.
Both of them have familiar aspects,
right? We see text boxes, we see the
plus to attach files, and so on.
But, the Teams chat assumes a much
higher level of familiarity. It's not
spelling out any of the iconography it
uses, and we don't see some of the
things intended to lower the barrier of
entry, such as the examples, large text
buttons, or voice interaction options
that show up on the agent chat.
Now, before we really dive into this, I
do think we have to take a moment to
address kind of the elephant in the
room, right?
Why not just have AI create these
solutions for us?
Why do we have to be the ones who design
and build new AI patterns when we have
technology that can generate interfaces
for us now?
The problem with that is that AI can
only really remix things that already
exist.
It's fantastic for looking at those
existing common patterns and replicating
them,
but the patterns for AI interfaces don't
fully exist yet. Or at the very least,
they are still in the process of being
rapidly developed, and they are changing
all the time as that technology
advances.
There's just not a long history of
standardized and familiar AI-related
interfaces that we can reference to
solve this problem.
So, at least for now, we're kind of on
our own here, and we can't yet defer it
to AI.
Maybe that will change down the road,
but for the time being, this is still a
very human problem.
Additionally, as many folks have begun
to notice, the design that an AI creates
is going to be a lot like every other
design out there.
AI can reference and remix, but you're
just not going to get brand new concepts
from it.
An AI-generated UI tends to look pretty
darn average.
And while that can be a really great
starting point, it's not usually a great
ending point.
If you just need a quick landing page,
it's probably going to do the trick.
But since we're dealing with whole new
interaction modes that need more
attention paid to the UX rather than
less,
it's just not going to be enough to get
us where we need to go right now at the
quality level that our users need and
deserve.
So, if we're going to build new patterns
and new interfaces to help our users get
the most value out of this technology,
where do we start?
Well, like most things in design, it's
best to start with the user.
Specifically, the user's problems.
That means that when we're thinking
about building our AI features, we need
to be thinking about what challenges our
users have with AI and the user flows
that will mitigate those issues as much
as possible.
From the user research I've been doing
and the users I've had the chance to
speak to, I've started to group the main
challenges here into five categories.
Trust,
clarity,
control, transparency, and meaningful
benefit.
In this talk, we're going to discuss
each of these in depth, understanding
the problems our users have when they're
using AI, and looking at some examples
of new patterns and techniques we can
employ to address them.
By making sure that we are addressing
each of these, we can start to create AI
experiences that support our users
through the introduction of this new
technology and ensure that they are in a
place to use it to its fullest
potential.
So,
let's get going.
>> [snorts]
>> Trust.
The number one, by far, biggest hurdle
that we need to overcome in order for
our users to engage with the AI features
we build is trust.
Right now, to the average user, AI is a
black box.
Many simply do not understand from a
technical perspective how it works.
And when you don't understand how
something works, it makes it very, very
hard to trust the output.
On top of this, just about everyone who
has interacted with an LLM before has,
at some point, seen them hallucinate.
Even as the models keep getting better,
we're still not at the point where we
can claim any tool will be 100%
guaranteed hallucination-free.
There's always a chance, even if it's a
small one, that the AI is going to
provide an incorrect response.
So, how many times can a user see output
that's wrong and still trust it?
It can be easy to think that the answer
to this problem is to try and position
the feature that we're launching as some
kind of exception to this rule. We say
things like, "Other AI tools may not be
trustworthy, but ours is different. Ours
is higher quality, it's safer, it's more
reliable." So on and so forth.
But not only is this questionably true,
right? I mean, after all, and not many
of us are really training our own models
here. So a lot of this is going to be
simply outside our control.
But it's also a very difficult thing to
try and sell your users on. In
situations where we cannot promise the
truth,
we have to go above and beyond to earn
it.
Our honesty about current capabilities
and limitations of our AI tools will go
a lot further with our users than the
denial of any potential problems.
So rather than trying to convince users
that our solution is inherently
trustworthy, we can instead build in
patterns that empower them to see when
incorrect information is returned and
give the tools to correct or mitigate
it. You know the saying, "Trust, but
verify"? That's kind of the goal here.
By citing the references in an
AI-generated response and linking users
back directly to the source material, we
give users the information they need to
validate AI output themselves.
The more a user is able to click through
and see where an answer came from, the
more they'll be able to trust the
content, even if they don't choose to
check every source every time.
In addition to allowing our users to vet
the answers, citations also have a
second important purpose.
They allow users to repurpose the
material in their own work while
maintaining a trail of accuracy.
This is really important for their own
credibility and reputation. After all,
how often would you share content from
an unverifiable source if you knew that
any errors would ultimately be attached
back to your own name?
Generating output for the user might be
the last step in our process, but it's
really just the beginning for them.
Users want to take that content and turn
it into a report, an email, a campaign,
a presentation. And if the output can't
be cited and trusted, then it's just not
going to be used.
There are a handful of different ways we
can implement this, and which one you
pick is going to depend on what you're
building and the context in which it's
being used.
But a few popular approaches include
things like tooltips, inline links, and
side panel reference windows.
Tooltips allow you to provide a small
snippet of a relevant quote, which can
be really great for increasing
credibility.
Links, of course, are ideal if the
content is coming from an external
source, like another webpage, as opposed
to an internal source, like a document
in a shared drive.
And if the feature you're building is
meant to support more research-oriented
work, then you might consider adding a
side panel, where the user can explore
the source material in more detail,
which kind of positions the AI assistant
as more of a librarian
than inherently a subject matter expert.
The other place where trust factors
heavily into AI work is agentic
workflows, where the AI is thinking and
executing work on its own.
This, understandably, can be kind of
concerning for users, depending on the
stakes of the project and how easy or
hard it would be to roll back any
incorrect actions, which is when keeping
that human in the loop really becomes
crucial.
One of the best ways to help users trust
these systems enough to use them is to
show an action plan to the user and
allow them to approve it before the
agent begins work.
This has become a pretty common flow in
a lot of foundation models, right? If
you're using agentic features in Claude
or ChatGPT, you will have seen it create
a list of the steps it will take to
accomplish a given task and then ask for
your confirmation before beginning.
Of course, there are also settings you
can add to toggle this off or always
allow it, all of which is important if
you're going to allow users to repeat a
flow over and over and don't want them
to have to baby sit it.
Spoiler alert, we will talk a little bit
more about permissions in the
transparency section later.
But if you're creating some kind of an
agentic tool and no plan is ever shown
to the user and an action happens
without them understanding why or how,
it can be very, very hard for them to
trust both the result of that action and
the agentic tool itself.
There is also, undeniably and I would
maybe even argue correctly,
quite a bit of skepticism around whether
or not content is AI-generated right
now.
You've probably seen exchanges online
where someone shares a photo or video
and another person is immediately
commenting to tell them that's not
actually real.
When we spend so much of our time and
energy second-guessing and investigating
content that's shared with us,
it doesn't exactly foster an environment
of trust.
For now, AI-generated content is highly
polarizing with users.
While some have heavily leaned into
using it in their daily lives, others
will react to it negatively and dismiss
it as slop, right?
The ability for AI to generate text,
images, and video that is nearly
indistinguishable from human-created
work is very new.
And for many users, that still feels
uncanny and unsettling.
I don't say this to start any kind of
debate, right? I mean, seems harsh to
say it, but our own personal opinions on
AI-generated content
don't really matter too much in this
context.
What's more important is the awareness
that our users will react to
AI-generated content in a wide variety
of ways
and not all of those ways are going to
be positive.
So, if we want to include AI-generated
content in our applications and we're
not exactly sure how our users will feel
about it,
what can we do to retain their trust?
One of the easiest things is to just
mark any AI-generated content as
AI-generated.
This could be as simple as a disclaimer
in the App Store description, a
watermark uh on a photo, whether that's
digital or visible,
or maybe even just an asterisk at the
end of a sentence that denotes something
as AI-created.
When we do this, we remove that
potential user perception of them
feeling like we tried to sneak
AI-generated content into our apps or
somehow like pull one over on them.
If we're using AI and we think it's the
right fit for our work, or we feel
strongly that our users should be able
to share AI-generated content, then
there's really no shame at all in
designating where it's been used.
Depending on where that AI is used, it
might also be helpful to clue our users
into which aspects of output they might
need to manually verify, rather than
having to review everything as though it
was AI-generated, if that's not truly
necessary.
Hand in hand with trust comes clarity.
Clarity is one of the most important
aspects of creating a good user
experience kind of generally, and the
stakes only get higher when we start
incorporating AI.
Because, as we said, so much of AI still
feels like an unknown to our users, we
need to be as descriptive and
straightforward about what's happening
at any given time.
The more insights we can give them about
what our software is doing and what they
can expect to happen next, the more
comfortable they will feel engaging with
AI.
I've noticed that there can be a kind of
impulse to frame AI to our users as
magic, right? We don't even have to look
further than the prevalence of the
sparkle icon to designate AI as an
example of that.
However, while that might feel kind of
mysterious and cool, it's really not
accurate, right? AI is just another
technology, and our users deserve
clarity over dramatics.
They want to know what's going on, how a
given output was created, and there's
really no reason for us not to pull back
that curtain whenever we can.
One of the most obvious ways for us to
do this is with streaming text or
similar live generation of content.
Not only is this a really great way to
disguise the latency issue of AI
generation, right? Nobody likes to watch
a loading spinner,
but it's also a fantastic way to show
the user what's happening in real time.
If we make the user wait until an entire
response is generated, there's a
non-zero chance that it won't actually
be what they wanted.
However, if we start showing a partial
response as it's being generated, we
give users the chance to start assessing
it immediately.
That means they can be coming up with
follow-up questions or adjustments or
maybe just stopping the process entirely
if it's not returning what they
expected.
This also keeps the user as an active
participant in the process, preventing
that like XKCD my code's compiling
experience of pressing a button and
walking away.
You've probably experienced yourself how
much harder it is to complete a task if
you are constantly disengaging from the
workflow.
Even if you know a process will only
take a minute, if there's not something
to keep you there, you're going to start
checking your emails or replying to
Slack messages or scrolling on your
phone and
just like that, a 1-minute wait has
become a 5-to-10-minute side quest,
making it much harder to pick up where
you left off.
The more we can prevent this for our
users, the more productive they can be
when they're using our tools.
Another thing that can help remove the
wall between the AI and the user is
having it think out loud as much as
possible as it processes a request,
especially in chat-based interactions.
Similarly to live streaming, this
improves the user's confidence level in
the output cuz they can kind of follow
the breadcrumbs and have a deeper
understanding of how a given conclusion
was reached.
After all, we do this all the time when
we talk to other people, right? If we're
presenting an idea, we know it's going
to be helpful for us to kind of talk
through the rationale behind how we got
there and why we think it's the right
choice.
Explaining ourselves is such a natural
part of human interaction that we've
really come to inspect it. And when we
don't see it mirrored in the systems
that we use, it can feel kind of
frustrating. Like something is being
unintentionally kept from us.
Additionally, seeing that chain of
thought process allows for better, more
accurate revisions when the output
wasn't what they expected.
If the user can understand all the steps
that happened between point A and F,
then they can really pinpoint where
things went off the rails. And that
allows them to give more specific
instructions or clarify ambiguous parts
of their request.
Some existing patterns are a little bit
easier to adjust from their previous
non-AI usage into this context.
And highlighting new content is one of
those. It's not groundbreaking, but when
it's combined with everything else, it
can be immensely helpful in helping
users keep track of AI actions,
especially in situations where an agent
is acting autonomously.
The basic idea is that when new content
appears or something gets changed or
updated, it gets specially marked for
the user in a way that draws their
attention to it.
Sometimes that might mean literally
moving the focus up or down the page to
see what's changed, right? Like when new
messages appear in an ongoing chat and
the message history scrolls down to
display it.
Other times though, it could just mean
drawing the user's eye back to a space
they might not have been actively
watching. Even if that doesn't include
literal movement on the page.
Things like changing the color of
revised text or putting a box or
highlight around new material or even
marking lines of code that are
different.
AI tools are often framed as being a
kind of personal assistant for the user,
an intelligent junior co-worker that
they can delegate tasks to.
However, as anyone who's ever delegated
a task can already tell you, sometimes
that means that things don't get done in
the way that you would have done them.
When users are working with our AI
tools, they need to know that they are
still ultimately the ones in the
driver's seat.
After all, there's very little value in
being able to assign the AI tasks if you
can't then step in as you like to make
adjustments, corrections, and fixes.
In that vein, it is also important for
the user to be able to stop or override
an AI action at any point, whether
that's during content generation,
partway through an agentic workflow,
when it's running code or scripts, or
something else entirely.
If the user is unable to abort the
process, then they're not actually the
one in control, and frankly, that's not
really acceptable.
One of the most reassuring things we can
offer nervous users is a clear and
prominent emergency brake that they can
slam to bring everything to a halt for
any reason.
That means it can't be tucked away in a
menu somewhere or involving some
specific command they have to remember,
which they won't in a high-stress
moment.
We want to give them the equivalent of a
big red button they can slam to make
everything stop whenever they need.
Of course, once a user has stopped a
process, we can probably guess what they
want to do next, right? They want to
undo the incorrect things that changed.
Even way before AI, Nielsen's heuristics
list safe exploration as one of the core
principles required for a good user
experience.
That means that users should be able to
navigate back and forth, click and
unclick things, and generally just kind
of mess around in a piece of software
without getting stuck or unintentionally
making big permanent changes.
Sometimes a user will try something and
then
change their mind, decide they don't
like it, or it didn't do what they
thought it would.
In those cases, we want to make it as
easy as possible for them to roll things
back to an earlier state.
This kind of safety net was always
valuable, but now that we're dealing
with non-deterministic output, having
some kind of a version history is going
to be pretty much a non-negotiable.
Of course, the level of version history
that's required will differ based on the
task. The Git style of version control
that we are used to as developers is
probably more than you will need in a
user-facing application.
If this is a truly simple conversational
interface, you may not need it at all.
The user could just rephrase their
question and try again if they don't get
the answer they wanted.
However, if your tool is doing something
more complex, like creating and editing
a document,
simple undo and redo actions that allow
users to move back and forth within the
last 10 or so steps would be really
helpful.
And if you're wanting them to do truly
advanced work with your tools, then it's
worth building in the mechanisms for
checkpoints or save states.
Consider what kind of tasks your user is
going to be working on with your AI
features, and think about how
significantly each step forward is
likely to change the existing content.
Ideally, this will also allow users the
specificity to make targeted targeted
adjustments. You don't necessarily want
them to have to wipe out and replace
everything that happened in a given step
if they weren't happy with it.
It's common for AI-generated results to
have a mix of quality in the output.
Users may want to keep some aspects
while reverting others.
And the more control we can give them
over that creative process, the more
enjoyable it will be for them to
collaborate with our AI tools.
This is especially true now as the cost
of tokens is starting to tick up.
Having granular control over what gets
reworked allows for more specific and
production productive iteration without
them just having to say, "Try again."
and start over from scratch each time.
AI tools are strongest when they
seamlessly integrate into the rest of a
user's workflow. Referencing internal
documents, sending emails, making
calendar appointments, drafting and
sharing content, so on and so forth.
However, most users won't integrate what
they can't see and don't understand.
If the AI applications we build are
going to become part of their daily
lives, then users need transparency into
exactly what they do, what they have
access to, and what it will cost them in
both time and money.
The more transparent we can make these
features, the less hesitation our users
will have in adopting them.
The concept of asking for user
permissions is certainly not AI
specific, but the stakes can feel a lot
higher when you're asking users for
permission to allow AI to act on their
behalf.
That means we need to make it easy for
users to see which applications we've
allowed our tool access to and in what
ways, keeping in mind that permissions
are often more than just a binary yes or
no.
So, can your agent just reference data
from this database? Or is it also
allowed to delete tables?
Can only read your user's emails, or can
it send from their addresses well?
Can it run scripts, search their local
files? Each one of these actions
requires direct user sign-off.
Permissions are also not a one-and-done
situation. A user might feel comfortable
allowing an action to happen once under
their direct supervision, but they might
not want to allow it permanently.
They could give access to a specific
folder, but not every folder.
They might approve an action, but then
want to be notified every time it's
taken.
Consider which of these gray zones might
exist in your permission structure and
try to accommodate as many different
options as you can.
Another common sticking point with AI is
data collection.
Often, it can be helpful to save
information from past interactions, but
storing this kind of data requires real
attention to user permissions and data
management.
If you want to create a system that can
remember things,
then you also need to make sure that it
can forget and that the user can not
only see, but has the final say in what
exactly gets remembered.
An ideal permissions flow will not only
ask for a user's approval in the moment,
but also create a space where they can
see the history of what they've given
access to and when,
as well as allowing them to revoke that
access or permission at any time.
Now, this one's pretty simple, so we
won't spend too much time on it, but
another crucial aspect of transparency
is making sure users know exactly what
they are committing to when they approve
an action request.
In addition to approving those actual
steps and plan, as we already discussed
in the trust section, they also need to
know how much time something is going to
take and what it's going to cost them in
money or tokens or credits, however you
are counting this.
Even if we can't specify an exact
amount, if we can provide a rough
estimate, that's generally going to give
users enough information to work with
and to potentially revise their request
if it's going to exceed what they're
comfortable with.
Similarly to the marking that denotes
which content was AI-generated, it's
also a really good example uh of an
chance to have a visual signal for when
an AI tool is acting independently.
If, for example, you're going to allow
an agent to take control of the user's
browser, then there needs to be some
kind of banner or sidebar or outline, an
indication that the user is no longer
driving that interaction.
Not only is this a good thing to do just
for transparency, so the user
understands the current state of the
system,
but it's also helpful to make sure they
don't unintentionally interrupt or
confuse an ongoing
process.
It's an especially important
consideration for processes that you
know are going to take an extended
period of time where the user might have
stepped away and then come back without
necessarily keeping track of everything
going on while they were gone.
Finally, all of the interesting
technology and cool functionality in the
world is meaningless if what we build
isn't solving the problems that our
users need solved.
To do that, we need to create
experiences that make it as simple as
possible for our users to get the output
they need from our AI features and start
to leverage it in their work or daily
lives.
One of the biggest mistakes we can make
when developing AI features is assuming
that our users know how to use them.
As mentioned at the beginning of this
talk, right? We know how to do things
like provide context or specify
formatting requirements or break large
tasks into smaller ones and then
iterate,
but our users often don't.
So, when we place a blank text box in
front of a user and just tell them to
ask AI, we're actually kind of asking
them to do a lot of work in figuring out
how to really use it.
They need to understand what kinds of
problems the tool can solve, how
specific they need to be, what
information the AI tool needs to
succeed, if they need to add sources or
references, how to recognize when a
response needs refinement.
Rather than expecting this level of AI
literacy from our users on day one,
we can help them by providing examples,
templates, suggested prompts, and guided
workflows that demonstrate what success
looks like.
Now, what will your users be doing with
the content that your AI feature
generates?
If they're going to run a search or
analyze a spreadsheet,
what happens next? What do they do with
the results? If they create an image,
who are they showing it to? How are they
sharing it? Is it getting printed or
posted online or sent to a friend?
By introducing next step action buttons,
we can make it as easy as possible for
them to leverage the output of our tools
in their own work.
If they're not able to action on the
content that was created,
it's never going to be more than a
novelty to them. It's not going to be of
realistic use.
But we can help guide them to suggested
next actions that will help them make
the most of what they created.
If we want to take this one step
further, we can start to build in direct
integrations with their other most used
tools. Like, maybe they want to generate
a new document with the content in their
word processing software from a draft.
Maybe they want to push new code to a
linked repo. Maybe they want to open a
new ticket in a tracking system with
their findings from a test.
The simpler we make it for them to get
the information from our tool into the
rest of their workflow, the more useful
it's going to be to them.
Now,
AI can generate content, write code,
analyze data, automate tasks, empower
our users to do all kinds of amazing
work.
But only if they're willing to try it,
and only if we make it easy enough for
them to do.
When everything our AI tools are doing
is hidden behind a curtain, it makes
users feel like things are happening
without their input, which is hard,
especially when many of them are already
kind of feeling some level of AI
skepticism or hesitation.
If we unintentionally create AI
experiences that take away our users'
power, understanding, and autonomy,
then they'll never be interested in
using what we build, because they'll
never feel truly comfortable engaging
with it.
By focusing on patterns that reinforce
those pillars of trust, clarity,
control, transparency, and meaningful
benefit, we can set guardrails around
our AI features that will help make our
users feel safe and confident.
Cuz the technology is here, right? The
models are already really good, and they
just keep getting better and better,
faster and more efficient.
That means that the differentiator for
the AI-powered software we build isn't
performance anymore.
It's the quality of the experiences that
we can build around them.
The line between design and development
is blurring a little bit more every day.
How users interact with the system, how
much information they see, how much
control they have, and how we earn their
trust are now questions that developers
have to consider when building
AI-powered software, whether your title
includes designer or not.
The technology may be incredible, but
for it to be truly successful, users
still need to be at the center of
everything we build.
Thank you guys very much for listening
to this talk. I really hope this is
helpful to you as you start integrating
AI features into your own applications
and software.
You can find these slides, as well as a
full transcript of this talk, at the
following links.
And, of course, feel free to reach out
to me online if you have any questions
at all. I'm always happy to chat.